Карл Лаґерфельд вперше показав
колекцію для дому моди Chanel
у своєму рідному Гамбурзі.
Концертний зал філармонії
перетворився на подіум.
Краса, спокій.
Збалансована, вишукана музика.
Чудові глядацькі місця, велика зала.
Я вражена наскільки чудові та легкі
індивідуальні елементи в колекції.
Кожна деталь сповнена емоцій,
які, як на мене, є сильними.
Понад дві тисячі гостей та клієнтів Лаґерфельда
з усього світу приїхали подивитися на колекцію,
в якій відчувався вплив портового міста Гамбург.
Модельєр використав елементи
крою одягу моряків,
головні убори схожі на морські,
крупну в"язку та кольори морської форми.
Карл Лаґерфельд - любитель деталей,
які обов'язково мають бути ручної роботи.
84-річний модельєр досі сам є дизайнером
усього вбрання своїх колекцій.
Він є неймовірним прикладом для нас усіх,
як бути безупинним,
і він залишається таким молодим
у своєму ставленні до життя.
Я вважаю, це те, чому ми маємо всі вчитися в нього.
Він ніколи не каже "ні". Він рухається.
Він вже обговорює, що робитиме наступного року
і ще через рік.
Ультракороткі сукні та лаконічні силуети -
Лаґерфельд в останній колекції для Шанель
звернувся до тенденцій модного одягу,
який носили в Гамбурзі в 60-х роках минулого століття,
і зірвав аплодисменти поціновувачів високої моди.